exciting group we have I know well I
know it's Cinco DeMayo
so
[Music]
or as the Schwarzenegger calls it
Father's Day Oh perfect for my audiences
they're just coming down from 420 roll
right into Cinco DeMayo but no I mean
good thing California has medical
marijuana because when the Republicans
get done with health care that is the
only treatment you're going to have you
saw what they did oh yeah okay yeah
never underestimate these bastards we
thought we had them a couple of months
ago health care came up in the house
didn't pass all these fuck-ups no they
did it they did it the other day they
told Jimmy Kimmel's baby go screw
yourself they told Jimmy Kimmel's a
candy let's start at the beginning we're
separating what I say with there you go
little tutorial we need anyway no the
house did it they you know they passed
the thing it basically lets the states
be the bad guys and deny coverage of
people with pre-existing conditions this
is what got by the way the moderate
Republicans on board the moderate
Republicans these are people who are
like you know I dabble in killing people
I wouldn't
I wouldn't call myself a murderer but I
and then the nerve of them after they
did this after they kicked 24 million
people or more at off health care they
threw a big party in the Rose Garden to
celebrate it there they are look at the
pipe fiving each other and congratulate
it look at all these white ass holding
somewhere there's an Elks Lodge going
where is everybody
Oh Trump got carried away and grabbed a
[ __ ] Paul Ryan
[Applause]
nobody was feeling very good about
himself
I know odd for him but at one point he
said how am i doing hey I'm the
president can you believe it no no
[ __ ] that's why we're investigating
Russia and then this to cap it all off
later in the day same day he meets with
the Prime Minister of Australia and he
says to him you have better health care
than we do they have government-funded
single-payer health care the very thing
he just signed off the opposite of any
other president this wing the stupidest
thing he said all week with this guy it
doesn't even cracked the top 100 he had
such a weak even by his standards in one
24-hour period political quoted a GOP
aide saying he just seemed to go crazy
today today I mean you heard you've all
heard by now right his tale of the
time-traveling Andrew Jackson right yes
okay so since we come on at the end of
the week I wouldn't go through all that
let me just give you some context in
this you know how Pete and cartoons
crazy people always think they're
Napoleon Trump thinks he's Andrew
Jackson and when I say he thinks I mean
Steve Bannon told him about Andrew
Jackson he didn't know who Andrew
Jackson was from LaToya Jackson m6
go all he knows now is that Andrew
Jackson is the president that same
people think as a monster but
shit-kickers love so ever since then
it's been Old Hickory all the time
accent on the hick he is from favorite
leader after Putin of course
and apparently Trump thinks that Andrew
Jackson is very angry that the civil war
happened 16 years after he died and
truck Trump said this is his quote
people don't ask the question but why
was there a civil war we got to find out
what the hell was going on in 1861
people aren't asking why there was a
civil war what they're asking is why are
we still using the electoral college
that's what we should be asking and by
the way and by the way mr. Trump if you
don't know what caused the Civil War and
why we were talking about that ask your
supporters they reenact it once a month